welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is cigar siddi Guillen who was at Yale
as the Henry Hart rice family foundation
fellow and lecturer her research focuses
on the notions of nationality
constitution and modern institutions in
Iran Iraq and Afghanistan during the
nineteenth and twentieth centuries she
is specifically interested in minority
groups in the Middle East today we
talked with Professor sadeghi on about
her manuscript titled non-muslims and
the constitutional revolution a question
of identity welcome professor sit again
thank you let's begin with an overview
of your book I understand you're still
working on it so tell us a bit about it
yes this is a manuscript based on my PhD
thesis which I wrote in French and it's
about the question of national identity
and religious identity concerning non
Muslim population in Iran and I focus on
four major communities in iran the
austrian jews christians and bahais and
I in the heart of the Iranian Society
circa 1892 1911 which was a kind of a
part of the period of transition toward
modernization somehow and I try to show
these communities in differently at
different levels national local and
international and I try to show how the
constitutional revolution which happened
in 1906 influenced or changed or may not
change the situation of these
communities and I also try to show the
role of these communities in the
revolution so tell me how you're doing
the research for the book this is a
historical research so I need to consult
lots of primary sources beside
the existing literature so I read lots
of travel logs memoirs journals and some
archival documents for this research
which is very noteworthy contribution is
the documents it introduces to the
academic board for the first time
because I consulted several archival
institutions in iran france and britain
including national archives diplomatic
archives and some archives of the some
institutions including alliances violet
universal and the lazarus the
congregation of the mission of friends
but something important is about the
foreign after archives in Iran in Tehran
it is very important because at the time
there was a special department in the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs which was
exclusively responsible for non Muslim
cases ok adoree Mlle Mouton ave which is
literally the department of diverse
people but in fact it was the department
of non-muslims so there I could find
lots of collections of non-muslim cases
individuals and groups which illustrate
the Iranian Society with regard to non
Muslim population it's very important
that I very good very good so tell us a
bit about the four groups you look at
you look at the National local
international level so talk about their
daily lives a little bit tell us about
them yes if you want to illustrate a
kind of daily life daily life of these
minorities the Austrians Christian Jews
and bahais one could see that they had
their own quarters separated from the
majority Muslim majority these quarter's
could be inside or outside the cities
and could have walls or gates or could
not have them but the goal was to
isolate the pop
relation and there were some regulations
and codes for them when they were coming
outside of their quarters but these
rules were very arbitrary and local so
sometimes for example you see that they
were not allowed to have the markets or
shops inside the city sometimes they had
to follow some dress codes for example
sometimes especially for the Austrians
and Jews they had two very patcher kind
of they call it vastly a kind of badge
to be recognized in the society and
sometimes they were not allowed to come
outside when it was raining because
non-muslims were considered impure or
nyjah's so the Tau test during the rain
this impurity with wash off Wow and
sometimes they were not allowed to ride
a horse or bicycle and that was a sign
of inferiority or humiliation and they
could be distinguished because of their
you know dress codes and appearance and
sometimes because of their language or
accent and sometimes because they were
following the rituals of their religions
but the most similar community to
Muslims were the Bobby Baha'i community
as far as dress codes or language we're
concerned they were so similar so they
could not be so easily distinguished in
the community because the Bob ISM
appeared in 1844 in Iran and obviously
the first followers were the converts
from other major religions and Muslims
in particular but something important is
that despite all these distinctions and
minority religious minorities would
communicate and interact with the
majority they would trade they would
marry each other and oh they would marry
yeah they would marry that there were
some rules of course but
that would happen and they recalled a
very communication with each other in
the daily life and it's important to
know that when we are reading documents
about the time normally we are reading
something exceptional because normally
we write reports and something unusual
happens something something abnormal or
occasional happens so it's important to
know that when we are reading the
documents we should not generalize it
through the whole society for all the
time so if we bear this in mind we
should see that we can see that there
were not very rigid borders and the
borders were flexible and sometimes
regulations would be postponed and even
ignored because of economic or political
reasons very interesting you also talked
about the constitutional revolution what
was the role of these religious
communities in the revolution yes the
constitutional revolution happened in
1906 in Iran and it's very controversial
because their research about this event
is very varied and their interpretations
are very conflicting but for me it's
important to focus on the goals of the
color of the Constitution in a special
one slogan that was Iran for all
Iranians so in 1906 the Shah of Iran
decreed it an order Fairmont and gave
the permission to establish the first
Parliament in Iran so the
revolutionaries deliver the
revolutionaries didn't accept that order
because they thought they they first
shot to change their order because he
mentioned Islamic Parliament and they
they had this demand to have a kind of
national or national parliament
so they changed the order and it was
very promising the situation was very
somehow democratic and for the same
reason non-muslims participated very
actively in the country to in the
constitutional revolution and they
helped the revolution financially they
participated to the army and they gave
lots of ideas and they helped it
culturally but when the Parliament was
established bahais and the other group
of the Baha Baha as Ali's were not
allowed to have it representative in the
parliament to them cause trouble sorry
did that make for conflict between the
groups no they were they were somehow
the pioneers of the revolution but for
the same reason maybe and because they
were not a recognized religion they were
not allocated something that a religion
that could live inside an Islamic
context they didn't have a right to have
a representative in the parliaments and
then Jews and Christians had a right to
have one representative each but they
were advised not to use this right so
instead they they chose too much their
heads cleric Islamic clerics to be their
representatives in the parliament and
only zoroastrians they managed to send
and representative in the parliament a
very famous and rich merchant who was
claimed to be the representative of the
merchants and not the zoroastrians so
that was the case of the you know
peasants of the non-muslims in the
constitutional revolution so what are
some of your findings regarding the
different political social and economic
aspects of Iranian Society with regard
to these different religions yeah there
are some lots of findings but I would
like to give you an example or two
you show how it worked how complicated
it wasn't very complicated yeah so I
would say a little bit about the
economic situation of non-muslims and
talk about it a little bit because at
the time non-muslims were not allowed to
choose their own job they were not
allowed to do any job they rich there
were some restrictions for example they
would only handle food and drink to
their own co-religionists they were not
allowed to deal with not a bit Muslims
in this sense and on the other hand we
had this Muslim community who were not
also allowed to practice some of the
services that the society was in demand
if they wanted it but Muslims were not
allowed to work with some special
materials for example they were not
allowed to work with gold chemical
liquids or they were not allowed to get
engaged in dance and music or producing
and selling alcoholic beverages so in
this sense non-muslims had the monopoly
of these activities these restrictions
enable the non-muslims to join different
levels and different classes social
classes and one group which was very
successful and they did well in economic
activities were the merchants non Muslim
merchants they normally had a kind of
connection and network inside and
outside the country with their own
co-religionists and families and that
would help them to manage their trade
and sometimes they had the monopoly of
some trades so they were very successful
and this success helped them to ignore
some of the restrictions that would be
imposed to non-muslim communities local
level for example they would ignore the
dress codes they would not
we're Badgers things like this and to be
successful on the other hand would raise
a kind of animosity or resentment from
the other side of the societies or
Muslim merchants did not like this so
they would find the kind of religious
pretext to limit their activities for
example they would force them to have
their markets or shops outside the city
or they would force them to pay some
extra taxes for example something like
Jessie J or gifts something similar and
sometimes they would incite the
population to under a kind of religious
pretext to attack their houses or shops
that would sometimes be encouraged by
clerics as well a merchant the
non-muslim merchant might be attacked or
even be killed because the kind of
religious or political authority was in
bed with him so sometimes that would
work as well so they would kill him just
to get rid of the debt and this this is
a situation and you can see that this
discrimination would sometimes encourage
non-muslims to go and ask for asylum or
ask a new nationality from other
countries such as Britain and Russia
Ottoman Empire or India and that would
bring other countries in the case and
there were frictions negotiations
regarding the non-muslims in this kind
of political relationship between Iran
and other countries so you can see that
there are different groups from
different religions in different levels
of the society at different levels and
it's not easy to decide that you know
just point out some of them sure I would
use fucose expression to say that there
was a kind of power network
and non-muslim community was a part of
this network and to use a gun bans word
I would say that borders and
distinctions were blared it was not very
rigid and i would say that these members
of the community had a kind of liquid
identity both in religion and bolting
nationality fascinating thank you so
much for being here with us today
answering some of your work thank you so
much for having me for more information
about professor said aghion and her
research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you